so my little brother is living in my  parents beach house in florida and he  decided to throw a party  open invite so naturally my friends and  i decided to run security at the party  so we're standing in front of the front  door and when people came up to us we  decided to make them do random things in  order to get inside okay this video is  absolutely trash i was trying to be  discreet but this is my friend taking um  this guy's temperature with a remote so  it didn't even work  and she's pretending to take his  temperature and then after i took his  temperature i informed him that i was  only allowed to let and cool people to  the party and in order to get in he was  gonna have to do push-ups so then  he started doing push-ups